this video is for everybody who was committed to diversity inclusion
let's talk about how to measure diversity inclusion
measuring diversity inclusion is not linear
it is so complex and actions speak louder than words
therefore an institution or a company's commitment to anti racism and diversity
and inclusion is not outlined in purely a policy
it is not outlined in a statement or an action plan
it is outlined in who they hire who they support
the type of people that they progress and why
watch how an institution treats those who were doing the work
this goes further if seeing if there is a diverse leadership
this goes further than filling a quota and it certainly goes further than tokenism
evaluating diversity and inclusion takes critical consciousness
it takes empathy
it takes a multicultural perspective and analysis
we must continue to strive for inclusivity